[Applause]
if i'm going to get conspiratorial i
think there might have been um
an organized effort to try to get you
out of there
there's a powerful man in media that's
attacking pedophiles and making it
really cool to get pedophiles of the
[ __ ] out of here
no talents for these pedophiles
meanwhile you got an international
pedophile ring bubbling up
with your boy jeffrey epstein he might
have felt like you were hot on his uh
his tail well you know there's an
interesting story there let's
talk about it in about
2015-16 i had a meeting down in florida
with a group of investigators
and uh some lawyers who are all involved
in the epstein
so there was a lot of information there
and epstein had served his you know year
in and out of the county jail and was
back living his life
and the information was compelling and
it was disturbing
and i tried to fashion a sting
and the security around his new york
residence
and around his life in general was such
that it was difficult to penetrate and
to figure out a way to do it and i
worked with some of the lawyers it was
before
a lot of the victims had actually come
forward victims who have now come
forward
and to be honest with you it's one of my
biggest journalistic regrets because
we worked it we worked it it wasn't
happening
i got busy with other stuff in the
meantime
here in miami much to the paper's credit
the herald
keeps pounding away and digging away at
it chipping away
day by day week by week and the herald
develops relationships with these
victims and ultimately the victims come
forward and tell their story in the
herald
and there's no question and the u.s
attorney
in manhattan at the time said this when
they charged epstein that if it wasn't
for
the miami herald's fine work right that
case may not have been prosecuted at
least not when it was
so the lesson to me is that sometimes
these things take years
they're not the automatic sting
operations that you want them to be
and you have to stick with it right can
you tell us a little bit about the sting
that you were setting up
we were in the initial stages um
working with a number of people who were
you know on the periphery of this
investigation
um of seeing if we could put somebody
in proximity who would be recruited
and then go into the epstein system
wearing hidden cameras
it never got that far but you think
today knowing what we know
having heard from these brave victims
who came forward
uh to make this prosecution knowing what
we know about the recruitment and the
enablers
jillaine maxwell et cetera yeah what
happened and and so
when i first got wind of the peter
nygard story
peter nygard was he's the the topic of
the new series on
discovery plus on seemly he's the
fashion mogul
who now is accused of human trafficking
and and all kinds of sexual assaults
going back some
50 years he had nygard fashion so every
pair of jeans that you would see
at a dillards and many other places that
was nygaard
close to a billionaire right he had a
major
uh estate in the bahamas and it was
right next to another estate owned by a
hedge fund guy
and they got into a beef over property
and one thing led to another and the
investigators from the hedge fund
louis bacon got involved and started
digging around
in nygard's business and found out that
he was you know
taking in young girls under age drugging
them raping them
i mean we're talking about potentially
thousands of victims
across the board this happened in l.a it
happened up in canada it happened
in the bahamas and for two years
i worked it worked it worked it and then
partnered with you know blackfin tv
and discovery plus and we were able to
to put this together
and not only was he involved in
in the sexual assaults i mean brutal
vicious controlling sexual assaults
but he was into this stem cell research
as an effort to prolong the fountain of
views yeah right oh yeah and so
he would go according to witnesses and
investigators he went so far as to
impregnate young girls have them get
abortions
harvest the stem cells to inject into
himself to prolong his life now is he
alive still
he's in jail up in winnipeg but is he
living longer
he's 79 and i'm told that you know
because he's
not been able to get bail which is good
and he's awaiting extradition to the
united states
indicted in manhattan by the u.s
attorney's office there
after a long investigation by the human
trafficking task force in new york
he's not able to get all his supplements
and his injections and
hormones so he's just wilting withering
away love it apparently yeah
but it that is fascinating because you
always hear this on like these
conspiracy chats people talking about
the um
elites drinking baby blood and like
sacrificing babies
and that kind of stuff but maybe that's
referential to the stem cell
well in this case it was and and you
know we in other words
um we started to get more and more
information his own one of his own
children came forward
uh nygard's son kaizen bickel who
is interviewed in in the documentary
you'll see it on discovery plus
and who has been on some of my shows on
youtube and some other things
who saw and something
that was inappropriate between his
father and a child at a dinner party and
started thinking he got involved and not
only did he help
investigators in this case but he was
actually interviewed for the documentary
which was a huge step yeah yeah
and very brave but it takes when we
commissioned the story
we didn't know that kai was going to
come forward we didn't know that
another source of mind would say hey
look talk to this lawyer he represents
the former videographer and creative
director for nygard who had hundreds of
hours of
videotapes on the private jet with the
stripper pole and the paper parties and
then going over to asia's
hamper party parties he used to have
these huge parties in la
and in the bahamas where you invite all
kinds of women okay
and they would get you know their nails
done and massages and makeup
and some of these girls would get chosen
drugged and taken away and
raped in fact one of the models
interviewed
yeah you thought they were putting
diapers on i thought they were walking
around pampers yeah no
no no no no no no that's what i thought
too oh well i could see
it yeah yeah okay so but one of the the
victims in this case
is the famous supermodel beverly peel
who was um signed a contract
with nygard for three years and she is
interviewed in the documentary and
you know it was the worst decision she
ever made and ultimately was sexually
assaulted by him and he had a child by
him
whoa yeah so this is checking out it's
called unseemly
and this is your show on discovery plus
yeah unbelievable
like unseemly isn't really a strong
enough adjective yeah
it's a play on the
[Music]
without the e like a liquor that's you
know maybe he's russian i don't know
yeah dude this that is absolutely crazy
yeah if you look at what
he looks like it is and so a year ago
literally it looks like mel uh mel blanc
on drugs whatever
mel brooks whatever yeah
you know i was always wearing a cowboy
hat jimmy goldstein yeah look at this
guy
nothing about him looks young who's the
chick to the left with the heaven
oh is that the beverly
come on yeah my bad i didn't know so
literally it was like it was like a year
ago last week that we got back from the
bahamas
interviewing all these victims his case
and it was
just a gut-wrenching experience
notwithstanding the fact that
you know it was a little edgy because he
had paid off a lot of government
officials in the bahamas
stuff so we're you know we're smuggling
these women in and out of this
safe house we're doing the interviews
and you know we came back i
believe was march 5th and it was right
before the lockdown happened
i mean literally it was the last trip i
made for
several weeks months because of the
pandemic and i remember coming back
through
um miami and we had added a couple days
to it and turned it into like a little
bit of a spring break because it was
staying down the bahamas and it was just
eerie coming back through miami you
could tell that people were saying yeah
uneasy about travel and we got back to
michigan and didn't move or you didn't
leave there for
did you know beforehand this is probably
the last set of interviews we got to do
so let's get everyone
it was the it was i think we all
remember the last set of international i
mean we you know look
we just did things remotely you know and
as things opened up we started getting
back to work on it but
literally because i was at you know our
house in michigan
we just had you know ordering television
equipment from
you know amazon or wherever to do the
youtube show to do this or that
and you know then you know the kids got
tired of having me at the dining room
table because yeah
two shows a week so i'd move him to the
basement yeah now we did more stuff in
the basement so we could light that up
properly
now you just adapted you said that you
were doing you were setting up this
sting for epstein
and then you got busy with other things
and it's hard to do
was there any pushback from the people
in the networks
was there did you feel there was anybody
protecting him at all
no it really didn't get that far but i
don't think there would have been
anybody protecting him we had
um we had
we would have had support for it yeah
because there in the past there has been
yeah but i gotta be honest with you you
know i have never
in 40 years had anybody seriously tell
me to back off a story
you